did Michelle yo save Star Trek for Alex
kurtzman welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so as you'll know if you're a regular
stock tracker I actually just got uh six
weeks ago so I said that actually the
section 31 is Starfleet Academy series
or project were very unlikely they were
very unlikely because it seemed very
unlikely for Alex kurtzman to get
Michelle yo to do section 31 and without
Michelle yo Paramount were not willing
to go ahead with section 31 or Starfleet
Academy
well as we've seen since he did get
Michelle yo to agree heir to a movie but
I'm going to talk more about that in a
minute so why did I get it so wrong well
basically because well I didn't there
were a lot of negative voices going
around Paramount this is a very
contentious subject apparently within
Paramount Executives and not everybody
agrees that Alex kurtzman's tenure ship
of Star Trek has been a success and that
to be honest makes sense because that
just reflects how the audience feel not
all of us love everything about new Trek
now I love bits I loved Picard season
three I actually love strange new worlds
I enjoyed parts of Discovery but not all
of it lower decks is great and Prodigy
genuinely surprised me it's if you
haven't seen prodigyx a lot of you guys
haven't because it's a kids cartoon
let's be honest watch it there were so
many Easter eggs in there that any track
you will love it so really honestly give
it a go so how did all this happen well
when Michelle yo left Discovery the plan
was to return for section 31 series that
was always the plan it was going to
return When Picard season 3 ended but
then Michelle yo got steadily busier the
thing that though really put a nail in
this problem is when she was cast in The
Avatar series because suddenly a lot of
her time over the next five years going
to be taken up by those series of movies
so a section 31 series it would take six
or seven months of the year up Suddenly
became very unlikely and Alex kurtzman
was aware of this however he kept
pursuing it now seven or eight months
ago it was common knowledge within
people in the industry that Starfleet
Academy was going to be the next series
but it went very quiet so it was assumed
Again by people in the industry that it
wasn't going to happen the Assumption
was it was a package deal section 31 and
staff Fleet Academy but both of those
projects relied on Michelle yo appearing
in section 31. Paramount were not going
to buy both seasons unless Michelle yo
did sign on the dotted line so Alex
kurtzman kept pushing it now as I've
talked to you guys before it was weird
that when April 5th came we didn't get
an announcement I talked to a guy that
works for quite a big marketing company
in Hollywood and he said this makes no
sense when Starfleet Academy was
announced a week before then he said
look they must have Michelle here they
must they must do it's the only thing
that makes sense they're announcing
Starfleet Academy a week before April
5th first Contact day because they're
going to announce the big project with
oscar-winning Michelle yeoh on that day
instead but then April 5th came and went
so again it became very confusing now I
then started hearing that actually they
were working hard towards a mini series
so I'm like you can't get Michelle Yeo
to do a seventh season series she
couldn't do it it's not possible so Alex
goes through and started the negotiating
well how about if you come back for just
a mini series for five hours a limited
series A one-off now that is possible
but then Michelle Yeo won the Oscar and
all of a sudden even that became
impossible but Alex kurtzman didn't give
up and he came up with this idea that
apparently has been kicked around for a
while about doing a movie straight to
Paramount plus a movie event that did
become possible but only because
Michelle yo was always Keen to do it
I've always been told that I've always
told you guys she's a really loyal
actress and she wanted to do this it was
simply timing
when was the problem
but a movie that would take two to three
months perhaps out of filming that is
possible also again talk to somebody
that I have been speaking to they're
saying there's already plans in place
for this they know that Michelle Yo's
um calendar is just insane so the idea
being that they're going to be filming
this movie really around her they're
going to be using a double basically
when they've got scenes when stuff's
going on and Michelle Yo's there but you
only receive the back of red it won't be
Michelle yeoh and then what they'll do
is they'll bring Michelle yo in and just
film her bit and basically paste it all
together so from a Time point of view
it'll be great for Michelle because you
won't be sat in a caravan waiting for
stuff she will just come on film go to
the next thing this has already been
planned out and to be honest it's not
new this is the sort of thing we've done
before when actors have busy schedules
Studios will work around it in very
clever ways so the information coming
out of Paramount about Star Trek is so
confused because there's so many
different voices
there are Executives within Paramount
that don't think Alex kurtzman should
keep Star Trek they think Star Trek
should be moved to a different
production partner and that there should
be a new vision for Star Trek going
forwards
but there are others that actually see
things like lower decks and are very
pleased with it that yes okay maybe
there was mistakes in on a discovery but
a lot of those mistakes have already
been fixed
and at the end of the day strange new
worlds was very popular but mainly
Picard season 3 was popular and honestly
if Michelle Yeo saved Star Trek pecan
season 3 did too because both of those
things have really made the doubters and
the people shouting anti-curtzman crap
very quiet the wind has really been
taken out of their sails because Picard
season 3 didn't just reach the top of
Paramount pluses streaming numbers it
got into the top 10 of all of the
streaming shows this has been massively
popular up until about episode five it
didn't look like this was gonna happen
the numbers were awful but around
episode 5 it really found the audience
and the numbers shot up now I did a
video actually telling people look no
one's watching the show it's it's
bombing we need to start getting into it
and luckily some of you listened but
also I'm sure a few of you just found it
on your own but at the end of the day
the show get watch but at the end of the
day people fell in love with the show
and that's all any of us wanted because
it's a good show so yeah they were major
doubts in Paramount about how well Star
Trek was being looked after by Alex
kurtzman and his secret hideout company
and those doubts are still lingering but
for now at least Alex kurtzman has won
the argument
Michelle yo is doing the movie this
movie event idea is hopefully going to
spread and we're going to see one every
few years and Star Trek's future with
secret hideout is at the moment very
secure
so let's hope that Starfleet Academy is
not Star Trek 90210 like we fear and
then actually it's something more in
vain with what we're getting used to
from things like Picard season 3 and
let's hope that it's Star Trek that all
of us trekkies can get behind because
that's at the end of the day is all us
sci-fi fans really want
but guys give the constant what you
think while Star Trek saved by Michelle
Yo's willingness to do this movie and
has the success of Picard season 3 been
just as important I'm really hoping we
get to hear an awful lot less negativity
coming out of Paramount about Star Trek
in the future against the comments and
tell me exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also if you would like to go over to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack you
get to see most of our new videos first
and for a small contribution each month
you get to see it without the adverts
you can get a T-shirt and mug and stuff
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
foreign foreign
[Music]